what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
another alpha male strategies video
um a lot of people have requested that i
react to him
and sometimes oh shoot hold on sometimes
he depresses me a little bit i'm like
not even gonna lie
like i can't even believe these guys are
real but
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
especially subscribe as you guys know
i'm trying to get to 15
000 subscribers so each and every one of
you helps me get there
okay um
the wall is a myth okay
let's let's figure out what this is
okay the wall is in myth
12 minutes long thank god you guys kill
me with some of the stuff you send me
it's like
two hours one hour like nah i don't got
time
like that
[Music]
what's up fellas so i had a loyal patron
supporter wanted to get
my opinion on the wall all right do you
think i'm like the only girl that
watches his videos you know he also
wanted to know do me and hit the wall
and for all you new guys that don't know
uh haven't heard of the wall is when
a woman has reached her
peak and now it's downhill from now so
she was like
hot then she hit the wall and then it's
just downhill from there well yes guys
i women do hit the wall but
it's i think a lot of you guys think
that this is an age thing like
you know a lot a lot of the mgtow's
challenge
try to put paint this as an age thing
like women
hit the wall at 35 to 40 years old some
saw me say they hit the wall at 30 years
old
okay with me is to me the wall is
primarily a woman's weight that's how i
always seen it now genetics gonna play a
small role into that too
but usually ninety percent of the time
guys at least
are not more the wall for a woman
really man you won't know what honest
truth for all of us is
weight your [ __ ] weight is going to
have a
great influence on your [ __ ] sexual
market value particularly women
yeah all right because we're men are
primarily visual
so that's how okay this is
absolutely true like any girl knows this
that if you are a certain weight
especially as a girl guys are different
but as a girl you get
like more attention so to speak
i've seen girls who like
on facebook started gaining weight
even before facebook right because
facebook ain't been around that [ __ ]
long so even before facebook i seen
girls
like when i would go out and see him at
the mall like damn i ain't seen this
girl in three years and she didn't gain
50 pounds
didn't we [ __ ] 21 22 years old
[ __ ] i'm already [ __ ] fat and then
you turn around and you look at [ __ ]
gabrielle union holly barrett j
lo tony braxton all the women like
over 50 i think gabrielle union is
coming up on fifth
it makes like 45 46 but the fact remains
is that
all those women still are hot as [ __ ]
and they
listen if you left me alone in the room
with tony braxton right now for the
weekend
when you came back monday morning you
wouldn't find that but her [ __ ]
eyelashes
i i break that old [ __ ] back right
[ __ ] now
and i think she 52 53 years old right
now
i tell her as up right now so
it really just boils down to a woman
taking care of herself it really has
nothing to [ __ ] do
with [ __ ] age in my [ __ ] opinion
now
yeah i just think as you get older like
it gets harder
because your metabolism slows down
and like plus a lot of people go to
college
and like drink a lot and plus like when
you can legally drink
like i feel like that adds a lot get
into a bigger a bigger thing for a lot
of guys i think a lot of guys
see women hit the wall and they think
like oh
you ain't gonna get no man almost i
don't know what [ __ ] world y'all guys
been living in but
obviously y'all ain't been living long
enough even if a woman is 600 [ __ ]
pounds
and don't baby for two months she still
probably have more options
than you unless you like a guy that's
pre-selected or something
the average man even if a 600 pound
fat whale made a dating app profile
she would get more inboxes a day than
you
you know why that is guys 80 of the
women in the world
[ __ ] the top 20 or at least that's a
theory which i
wholeheartedly believe i wholeheartedly
believe that
okay eighty percent of the women in the
world [ __ ] the top twenty percent of men
so the other eighty percent of men are
scrounging around
for the bottom twenty percent okay guys
and so what that means is that even
these [ __ ]
whales are going to have more options
than you
that is the but i i don't i don't agree
with that
that's not true well i guess it depends
on the guy right tell you what
if i'm lying i want you to put in the
comments of a video
of a woman complaining that she's in
sale and she can't get no dick i want
you guys to put that in the [ __ ]
comments if you can find that picture
only of that video on youtube i want you
to put put that in my [ __ ] comments
damn damn that's a good point you want
to see it oh you all like
how y'all got all these in cell videos
and guys want to do this and do that and
they shooting up schools
i want you to show me a woman on youtube
that's sexually frustrated like that
you ain't gonna [ __ ] find it what you
will find is women that are frustrated
that they can't get a relationship
and for all you guys that are that say
well i do know women that are mad
that you know they ain't got a man and
[ __ ] like that they mad because
they mad because they can't find a man
that want to give him a relationship a
serious relationship that's what they
[ __ ]
said now they dating with a purpose okay
when they want a purpose he walked
around
twisting her ass when she thought she
was hot [ __ ] right and now
she's [ __ ] 45 and now the [ __ ]
dating with a purpose yeah
you'll see those they want they they
tired of running into [ __ ] boys
so now that they [ __ ] now they dating
with a [ __ ] purpose yeah you you will
find women that are frustrated like that
but what you won't find is a video woman
who's not even getting no men
approaching them
they give me an approach now even the
[ __ ] that are complaining about they
can't find a man
uh get a man and [ __ ] like that what
they they ain't complaining they can't
get no dick
they complaining that they can't get a
man that want to take him out and all
it's not a [ __ ]
they keep me men that want to come
straight over and all that [ __ ] so
in that aspect yes i guess you know
but you know what i won't even go that
far
you know what that be guys you know but
i would still disagree there like
even those girls
usually there's like a guy that wants to
date them it's just not who they want
what those women be complaining about
they want the alpha male yeah they want
they want they want
they are mad that they can't get the
alpha male to want to be in a
relationship it's plenty of [ __ ] beta
male cooks that are uh
a wife them uh married to [ __ ]
in a heartbeat
they get plenty of them see they they
mad if y'all guys go back and watch the
video while talking about derrick
jackson
that's what i was talking about all
those women over there crying about
fuckboy fuckboys what they mad about is
they mad that guys like me
don't want to be in a relationship with
the ass but they got plenty of guys in
the friend zone
that would not love nathan that's better
doing them in a relationship but they
don't want them
see they don't want them see they they
are contradictory
to their own [ __ ] way of thinking
okay so yes you will have women that
women that are complaining about that
they can't get a man well they should
phrase it as in
they complain that they can't get the
man that they [ __ ] want they want to
chase the alpha male they wanna they
want the guy
who's [ __ ] everybody to be in a
relationship with the ass and it don't
work that [ __ ]
well and i don't think a lot of girls
like actually know
these statistics and they don't realize
like what comes
with like dating guys like that
can wait okay guys so that's that's the
situation with that
as far as men hitting the wall men hit
the wall guys
when our sex appeal doesn't keep up
with our financial situation so let me
put it to you guys like this right here
right
as you guys age as you guys age
and you start you still dating women
your
sex appeal is going to start to matter
less and less to women
okay so as we men let's say you're 21
years old
and your sex appeal is here and all i
know looks a subjective but let's just
say
you at your maximum sex appeal and and
guys
change this [ __ ] some guys you know do
the self improvement
and they get their sex appeal later but
i'm just speaking of when you
reach your sex appeal that's not normal
though most people gain weight as they
get older peak
so let's just say 21 you right here
but your finances right here you ain't
got [ __ ] as your sex appeal come down
you're providing supposed to come up
okay
if this don't improve so let's say
you're a 21 year old guy
and i'm just gonna throw some numbers
out there let's say you're making 20
grand a year working a job
when you're 30 years old if you're
making that same 20 grand now
now that your sex appealed and came down
you're gonna struggle in the day market
point blank period because now at 30
years old you're gonna start dating
women
usually you're gonna start dating women
that now they're starting to mature
and their maternal instincts are
starting to kick in they're not gonna
consider you
you're gonna be null involved you're
gonna struggle all right when you're 21
you can get away with that hey he cute
and and beyond that right and like when
you're younger
like if a guy doesn't have his stuff
figured out when he's younger
i think a lot of girls will think like
oh he'll figure it out later or like
he's building something whatever but
if you're like 30 35 and you don't have
anything
like you've had time like it's not like
it's not like you just left the house
beyond that
when you're 21 years old women will give
you a break
you're 21 [ __ ] years old what the
[ __ ] what is the [ __ ] expect you 21
years old you just got out of school
what the [ __ ] i'm supposed to have a big
ass house and a nice car and a [ __ ]
um fortune stashed away hell [ __ ]
knowledge so women give you a break
you're 21
hey whatever they start to expect more
out of you as you get older okay
so if i'm a 40 year old guy you know and
and i'm struggling they're not gonna
give me the same benefit as they would a
21 year old guy going through the same
thing
do y'all guys understand that well and
you have to think about if they're
financially responsible because you've
even if you're not making a lot of money
like you should still be saving like 20
to 30
of your income so if you're 40 and you
have
no savings like
that's that's a reflection on like the
choices you made in your 20s and your
30s so
if as our sex appear as a man sex appeal
comes down
you will hit the wall and you will
struggle and you won't have no [ __ ]
options
if your income don't come up
all right anytime i get a little 50 cent
raise you're gonna get a
heater that ain't i'm coming out you you
need to stop making some serious
paper as you get old all right as you 45
years old
you need to be making some good money
compared to to where you live it all
right
so if it don't you gonna struggle and
this is important for you
especially you red pill guys over here
that are gonna date and not settle down
this might not be that important for a
guy who a purple peel guy who's gonna
get married and this that another
that's this might not be that important
right but as guys
who gonna constantly date and [ __ ] like
that yes
as you lose as as we get older and you
lose sex appeal
you lose your sex appeal you ain't as
sexy as you once was
your income has to more than make up for
it if it don't you are going to [ __ ]
struggle
but as far as women hitting the wall
guys the only way a woman hits the wall
is she gains weight
and even then even then it's only going
to be about she can't
get in a relationship because if you
guys watch the 600
600 pound life i've literally seen this
i know what he's going to say and i've
literally seen that show and thought the
same thing
y'all guys will see those women always
have boyfriends and husbands
now you get those 600 pound guys on
there they are always 33 year old
virgins
that should tell you guys something that
should tell you it is always going to be
some [ __ ]
now the the thing is is what you'll see
is
you have some women that are reasonable
that they'll understand that hey
i'm not as hot as i was when i was 35
i can't command the dude that i used to
command
and so what they do is they'll get on
their [ __ ] and complain
that they can't get that guy that high
value guy to get in a relationship with
they can [ __ ] him
see that's the thing they can [ __ ] him
they just can't get him in a
relationship
so if you want to say hit the wall as
far as being able to get in a
relationship with the guys
like they used to i guess so but women
always will be able to [ __ ]
women will always be able to attract a
man i'm i'm i'm sorry to break that down
to you guys
but women are this is guys this is
this is the one video because i actually
agree i've been saying this
like they make it seem like it's like
over
when you hit a certain age but it's just
not true there's always
like if the stats are true that 20 of
the men get 80
of the women that leaves 80 guys look at
only fans
you got guys over there paying 20 or 30
a month
to [ __ ] look at ass come on so if you
if you think guys are paying 20 to 30
dollars to look at girls
on only fan do you really think women
around here going around i can't find no
dick i can't find no dick no man
man even fat girls get guys
approaching them that's the thing guys
okay so to conclude the women hit the
[ __ ] wild way it just depends on
what's your definition of the wall
as in for as is they're gonna get to a
point to well
they aren't as sexy as they used to even
that is going to be relative to the
woman if you take care of yourself like
i said tony blacks
braxton gabriel union j.lo holly berry
them women still look [ __ ] good
those women i would still [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of any one of those women right now
and they all
at 50 are over 50. right now i [ __ ]
you guys would too
okay so it just depends on how you take
care of your [ __ ] self that's usually
going to be just a woman's weight if a
woman takes care of herself man she can
look good
all the way up into a 50s easily if she
take care of herself
the problem is most women as like we age
we get more sedentary right we get a car
we start driving everywhere
so you get more sanitary our metabolism
slows down every year
so the weight starts to come on and then
they hit the wall but i've seen women
hit the wall at [ __ ]
20 man fat as [ __ ] okay so it ain't
really got nothing to do with [ __ ]
age it's just
it just really depends on what show you
guys
definition of hitting the wall because
women will always have [ __ ] options
there's always going to be some [ __ ]
sim
looking for some ass
oh my god this guy's kind of funny let
me know in the comments
if you agree or you disagree with him in
the comments
do you think the wall is real or do you
think that is something
that basically says that girls got out
of shape let me know in the comments
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe